[Música]
hola a todos un gusto tenerlos
nuevamente aquí en france24 esta es la
cuarta entrega del diario en vídeo de
toma para skate el astronauta francés ya
ha completado dos tercios de su misión
alfa de seis meses de duración a bordo
de la estación espacial internacional
que contiene un laboratorio con
propiedades únicas por esta razón la
principal ocupación a bordo de la
estación es la ciencia y los
experimentos son el día a día de los
astronautas ya de un módulo dedicado
para ello que es donde toma pesqué pasa
la mayor parte de sus días y el bien
llamado laboratorio allup empecemos con
esta visita guiada vamos a hablar un
poco sobre ciencia y también sobre la
vida cotidiana a bordo de la estación
espacial nos encontramos en el módulo al
que llamamos el lab el laboratorio que
es el corazón de la estación donde
empieza cada día el día empieza a camps
parece que no pasará gran cosa pero cada
mañana tenemos una pequeña conferencia
con el centro de control en la tierra
repasamos el plan del día hacemos
nuestras preguntas eso sucede acá
utilizamos este micrófono para
comunicarnos por radio tenemos
diferentes canales de comunicación una
vez que todos nos ponemos de acuerdo
empieza el día les voy a mostrar un poco
de lo que sucede en el laboratorio este
es uno de los módulos más grandes de la
estación detrás de cada superficie
sucede algo por ejemplo este es un
equipo para aplicar el co2
esta es una estación de control para el
brazo robótico está la estación de
entrenamiento para el brazo robótico
almacenamiento y a medida que avanzamos
verán que tenemos muchas computadoras
portátiles colgados por todos lados
también tengo mi ipad en la pierna mi
tableta nos va a permitir acceder a
nuestros procedimientos a los documentos
que el centro de control pone a nuestra
disposición para ayudarnos a examinar lo
hecho en el día y hacer nuestro trabajo
computadoras portátiles por todas partes
tenemos cosas en el techo encima de mí
tenemos lo que llamamos un rack express
el cual simplifica el envío de
experimentos científicos a bordo de la
estación estos pequeños módulos que ven
acá son intercambiables tenemos
congeladores refrigeradores experimentos
algunos que nunca había visto antes ni
siquiera sé lo que hacen pero todo es
intercambiable parecido a un tetris a
veces instalamos nuevos módulos los
experimentos vuelven a bajar a la tierra
por lo que es aquí tenemos nuestra
bicicleta estàtica para mantenernos en
forma lo hacemos todo en este mismo
módulo y por acá tenemos un lugar que es
bastante interesante porque tengo un
cariño especial nuestra ventana de
observación es desde aquí que tomamos
muchas de nuestras fotos de la tierra
tenemos una vista vertical que es
absolutamente magnífica una ventana de
una calidad óptica incomparable que nos
permite usar cámaras con lentes muy muy
grandes para tener vistas con zoom de la
tierra a todos los astronautas nos
encanta hacer esto y cada uno trata de
encontrar sus lugares favoritos
las famosas cámaras están aquí ya ven
que son lentes impresionantes pero ese
es el precio que se paga para conseguir
fotos de la tierra seguimos más de lo
mismo aquí ciencias de los materiales
aquí detrás de esta pared de ciencias de
la combustión aquí tenemos nuestros
experimentos sobre los átomos super trío
se acerca a los cero grados kelvin
equipos por todas partes a esto hay que
acostumbrarse electricidad electrónica
aquí está la caja de guantes se
despliega así nos permite realizar
experimentos aislándonos del resto de la
estación por seguridad por su seguridad
para que no nos contaminemos por nuestra
seguridad dependiendo de los productos
que se utilizan también tenemos cámaras
de vídeo por todas partes porque a veces
el centro de control necesita saber lo
que estamos haciendo para ayudarnos y
eso nos ayuda mucho dejamos las cámaras
encendidas no es gran hermano pero de
vez en cuando lo necesitamos
aquí como ven estas son las bolsas de
transferencia de carga no las guardamos
especialmente para ustedes son una
especie de bolsa de transporte lo que
llamamos ctv y se han convertido en una
unidad de medida de volumen a bordo de
la estación el peso cuenta en el espacio
pero cuenta más en el volumen y éstas
etb nos ayudan a transportar los equipos
esta es media ctv
05 pero tenemos ctv es de uno de dos
esta es realmente la unidad de volumen a
bordo de la estación finalmente quizás
el último lugar interesante de este
laboratorio sea el mail fit un
congelador que llega hasta los menos 80
grados los experimentos científicos
implican un montón de muestras ya sea de
sangre de orina de pelo incluso de cosas
más locas y para poder bajarlas a la
tierra las congelamos voy a abrir solo
para mostrarles es impresionante aquí es
donde podemos almacenar todos nuestros
experimentos al menos 80 grados lo que
más nos nos ponemos guantes pero no voy
a tocarlo y habrá un vehículo que bajará
la tierra y lo llevará todo en pocos
minutos vieron un día completo en la
estación el día comienza con la reunión
sigue con el ejercicio luego unas
cuantas fotos y después mucho trabajo
con el equipo científico terminamos
poniendo los experimentos aquí y luego
volvemos a tener la reunión para
concluir el día ahí lo tienen hicieron
parte de un día de mi vida como
astronauta gracias por haber estado
conmigo
y no olviden que cada mes toma pesqué
nos entrega detalles de cómo es su día a
día en la estación espacial
internacional y los avances de su misión
y ustedes lo podrán conocer sólo aquí en
france 24 gracias se los invitamos a
seguir con nuestra programación
[Música]